Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two.
David P..
I have to tell you, I'm worried that I am
just terrible at communicating with my audience.
And what I mean by that is sometimes I think
I'm being clear about what I'm saying.
And then I get a voicemail like this one and
I start wondering what the hell is going on
with my communication skills.
Maybe I really can't express myself effectively.
This is related to my story last week about
what's going on in Haiti and explaining some
of the racist analysis of the economic differences
between Haiti and the Dominican Republic.
And then I got this voicemail.
Take a listen.
Speaker 3: David, sir, sir, a shocking about
man, and I'm talking about the segment that
you did in regards to Haiti and the Dominican
Republic.
OK, that.
We come from the European descent, which I
absolutely disagree, being Dominican, from
the Dominican, born and raised in the Dominican.
Matter of fact, if you pay attention to any
sports that includes Dominican players, most
of the players that you will see are not of
European descent.
We have old range of colors when it comes
to people.
We have black, we have whites, and we have
a lot of in between.
Right.
And for the most part.
We are compromise in the population.
I'm talking about all people that are either
of darker skin color.
Speaker 1: Listen, what I explained last week
was for people who may be aware that Haiti
and the Dominican Republic share an island,
the island of Hispaniola.
But Haiti is significantly worse off economically.
I wanted people to know that there is a very
common racist's story that's told about why
the Dominican Republic is better off than
Haiti.
The story that the racists tell is Haiti is
mostly people of African origin, black people.
Where is the Dominican Republic is much more
significantly comprised of what we would call
Latino and European origin, meaning white
people.
Now, the actual breakdown is that Haiti is
almost completely African, whereas the Dominican
Republic is only 11 percent African, 16 percent
white.
What we would call European and seventy two
percent mix, which includes European and other
things.
OK, I wasn't saying the Dominican Republic
is a European country.
I was explaining that the truth about the
disparities between Haiti and the Dominican
Republic are quite complex.
And they relate to geography.
They relate to whether they relate to deforestation
and that Jared Diamond has written a lot about
this.
That's the real story.
The wrong story is that there are people who
like to just say Haiti is worse off because
it's mostly black people and the Dominican
Republic is not.
And that's true.
But am I really I mean, should I quit?
Is that I feel I don't know if it's me or
it's somebody else, but I feel like I am not
I must not be communicating effectively, as
I was trying to say, this is the story that's
told.
It's a wrong story.
OK, let's move on.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
The World Health Organization is warning against
mixing and matching covid vaccines, but many
people are doing it.
And I know people, in fact, that have done
this.
We will also talk about the Gavin Newsom recall
in California and we will talk about millennials
living paycheck to paycheck on over one hundred
thousand dollars a year.
OK, all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show.
Don't miss it.
Sign up it.
Join Pakman Dotcom to get instant access and
I will see you about.